short-term rentals are now officially
legal in unoccur unincorporated clark
county well this after commissioners
passed new rules to regulate them this
afternoon madison kimbrough is live in
our newsroom with all that information
on madison this is a big deal for
several areas around town yes it was a
unanimous vote by the board of
commissioners in favor of making
short-term rentals legal this is the
first time they are being made legal in
unincorporated areas of clark county
since previously companies like airbnb
and verbo were not allowed the nevada
legislature approved ab 363 last year
which required the county to adopt and
enforce an ordinance that would regulate
these rentals many homeowners over the
course of several months have attended
these meetings stating the reasons why
they want short-term rentals to be legal
while there may have been some who have
opposed to the idea stating that it
would harm their neighborhood and why
each person will be limited to one
license a limit of 10 people will be
allowed in each rental and properties
must be at least 2500 feet away from a
casino resort now also there must be at
least a thousand feet between properties
we will have all the new regulations
it's up on our website right now at
8newsnow.com
in the newsroom madison kimbrough live
local now